[Musique]
bonsoir à tous bienvenue sur rt france
pour une heure et demie d'émission nous
décrypterons comme chaque soir du lundi
au jeudi l'essentiel de l'information
avec nos invités et nos reporters sur le
terrain une émission essentiellement
consacrée à la crise du coronavirus en
france et dans le monde
voici les titres de l'actualité elle 5,7
pour cent des français auront été
infectés par le coronavirus au 11 mai
selon des estimations de l'institut
pasteur
loin de l'immunité collective souhaité
par les autorités et qui permettrait
d'éviter une seconde vague de
contamination les débats sur le tracking
et le déconfinement progressive seront
finalement suivi de vote au sein de
l'assemblée répondant ainsi à une
demande de l'opposition et soirée dans
ce contexte tendu du confinement que des
tensions une nouvelle fois éclaté la
nuit dernière dans certaines banlieues
notamment villeneuve la garenne après un
accident entre un motard et la police
peut-on craindre un embrasement on ses
quartiers ce sera l'objet de notre face
à face à 20h15
[Musique]
une chute spectaculaire celle de l'or
noir américain trop d'offre des zones de
stockage saturé résultat après deux mois
de chute
la valeur du baril coté à new york hier
soir
en dessous du zéro dollar du jamais vu
de son côté rien dit surveiller les
marchés se dit prête à agir plusieurs
pays de l'opep se sont entretenus de la
situation dramatique du marché du deux
sont 6000 morts en europe dont près de
22 mille morts en espagne qui connaît un
léger rebond dû laisser duo kobe 19 ans
24 heures d'autres pays du vieux
continent
entamant ce début de semaine un
déconfinement progressif comme
l'allemagne la norvège ou le luxembourg
le port du masque obligatoire accompagne
bien souvent ces retours à une liberté
relative
[Musique]
la france déplore près de 21 mille décès
dus aux coronavirus annonce du directeur
général de la santé jerôme seine au mans
il y à quelques minutes le solde
d'admissions à l'hôpital demeure négatif
avec 478 personnes hospitalisées en
moins par rapport à hier c'est une bonne
nouvelle le nombre de personnes en
réanimation baisse lui aussi pour le 13e
jour consécutif
117 1324 cas serait confirmée selon les
estimations de santé publique france les
données hospitalières font l'objet de
remontées quotidienne de 1300 un
établissement de santé
trente mille cent six personnes sont
actuellement hospitalisés pour une
infection coheed 1885 nouveaux patients
ont été hospitalisés
ces dernières 24 heures mais en tenant
compte des sorties le solde reste
négatif avec 478 personnes hospitalisées
en moins par rapport à hier 5433
patients dans un état grave
nécessite une hospitalisation en
réanimation au cours des dernières 24
heures 190 nouveaux malades ont été
admis dans un service de soins intensifs
de soins continus ou de réanimation le
solde reste négatif pour le 13e jour
consécutif
il est de 250 patients en moins en
réanimation dans les outre-mer on relève
81,18 hospitalisation c'est une baisse
de 10 admission de 32 patients en
réanimation là aussi le chiffre baisse
doucement et ses informations précieuses
fournis par l'institut pasteur à présent
environ 6% des français auront été
infectées par le virus au 11 mai date du
premier déconfinement or il faudrait 70
% des personnes immunisées pour parler
d'une immunité collective
de quoi faire quand d'une seconde
de contamination dans l'hexagone les
estimations de l'institut montre par
ailleurs une répartition inégale sur le
territoire
dans les régions les plus touchées vous
le voyez comme l'île de france où le
grand est le taux serait respectivement
de 12,3 et 11 8% mais de seulement 1,9
pour cent dans les pays de la loire ou
de 1,4 pour cent renouvelle aquitaine
des régions épargnées jusqu'ici et pour
en parler nous sommes avec pierre
salliou professeur agrégé ovale de grave
ça bonsoir professeur merci d'être avec
nous de nous accorder un petit peu de de
votre temps précieux
ces temps ci alors 6 % des français
infectées au 1er mai selon l'institut
pasteur pas suffisant selon vous
également pour éviter une seconde vague
redouté bien sûr pas suffisant mais
enfin tu d'hermach vous venez de dire
que c'était une estimation
certes basés sur des modèles
mathématiques qui sont certainement
performant avec des biostatisticiens de
l'est du pasteur et leurs collaborateurs
mais pour l'instant ce n'est qu'une
estimation
ce qui est certain c'est
qu'effectivement le taux réel de
personnes infectées et sûrement tout à
fait inférieur à ce qu'on appelle le
taux nécessaire pour avoir l'immunité
troppo la heures des multi et donc pour
éviter donc effet que pour arrêter
l'épidémie
mais on pourrait avoir des idées plus
précises quand on aura des tests
sérologiques car aujourd'hui nous
n'avons pas encore de test sérologique
pour pouvoir faire des enquêtes
sérieuses gic qui nous donneront des
chiffres plus précis et encore une fois
qu'ils sont certainement inférieur à ce
qu'on aurait pu attendre ce qu'on aurait
pu à temps mais finalement heureusement
c'est une preuve que notre confinement a
été bien respectée car la transmission a
beaucoup diminué
il ya un chiffre qu'il faut peut-être
ajouter c'est ce fameux air 0 qui a
diminué considérablement
considérablement car il est passé de 3 3
% environ au début de l'épidémie amen
à un peu plus de 0 5%
mais pardon pardonnez moi oui continuez
votre explication
oui donc ce que je voulais dire c'est
qu'effectivement la couverture donc
immunitaire est tout à fait insuffisante
pour éviter le chêne le phénomène de
rebond
sauf et c'est le sauf qu apporte
important et capital si on continue à
respecter les mesures barrières et si on
continue à respecter les mesures
barrières on va on va pouvoir maintenir
le r0 ou du moins ce qu'ils n'augmentent
pas beaucoup et donc il fini nous allons
nous devrions quand même réussir avec
d'autres facteurs à contre contrôler
sans être trop populiste à contrôler
donc cette épidémie qui s'est passé tout
à fait mais alors justement la nuancer
avec d'autres facteurs ces facteurs là
est ce qu'on les a aujourd'hui vous
venez de le citer vous même les tests
sérologiques est ce qu'ils ne sont pas
une pièce absolument maîtresse de ce
succès dans la lutte du coronavirus or
on le sait qu'ils ne sont pas prêts
aujourd'hui c'est ce que j'ai dit
malheureusement ils sont tant ils sont
en évaluation et pour est en cours
d'homologation
mais à ma connaissance ça devrait être
ces jours ci on les attend là vraiment
tous les jours et j'espère que les
industriels suivent derrière pour être
prêt à les mettre sur le marché dès
qu'ils seront homologués mais
aujourd'hui on ne peut pas faire encore
des grandes enquêtes sérologique par
faute de test effectivement alors
professeur on nous parlait de l'immunité
on oublie souvent qu'il faudrait 70 %
pour jouer l'immunité collective on a du
mal à comprendre dans le contexte de
confinement
c'est une mission impossible on aurait
dû peut-être s'y prendre autrement dans
la stratégie écoutez je n'en je réponds
même carrément non parce qu'il ya deux
solutions
je crois que c'est air hébété mais il
faut être simple et les expliquer
simplement la solution c'était de
laisser circuler le virus comme on sait
que l'immense majorité des cas sont des
cas bénins mais à quel prix c'est les
personnes âgées et on ne peut qu on ne
pouvait pas gérer ces circuits le virus
pour faire une hécatombe encore plus
chez les personnes à risque et les
vieilles personnes où il ya des ehpad et
c'est donc non c'est sûrement là la
bonne solution mais c'est clair que du
coup on n'empêche que cette immunité
collective puisse s'étendre suffisamment
alors l'étude pasteur qui estime que 0,5
pour cent des personnes infectées hummer
évidemment plus meurtre meurtriers que
les grippes saisonnières mais je
voudrais la ville une professeur de
médecine que vous êtes
est ce que c'est un chiffre qui est
vraiment très important comparé aux
autres causes de deux décès en france
alors là je biaiserait un petit peu pour
répondre à cette question
ce que l'on voit actuellement et le
directeur général de la santé le répète
tous les jours c'est qu'on voit quand
même une augmentation par rapport aux
autres années de la mortalité
donc c'est clair que l'effet qu'ovide
augmente la mortalité
ça c'est certainement oui alors
l'institut pasteur également avec son
étude 1 qui révèle une répartition très
peace riz précise par région 1 2 3 %
notamment à paris 1,4 pour cent
nouvelles aquitaine déjà comment
l'expliquer et puis cette répartition
peut-elle être pérenne est ce qu'il ya
des régions selon vous qui vont rester
totalement épargnés je ne crois pas je
ne crois pas il y aura sûrement quand le
confinement va être terminé
donc on pourra quand même circuler il
est évident que le virus
circulera aussi encore une fois c'est
les ports et dont il circulera et dans
les régions qui pour l'instant sont peu
atteinte mais en respectant encore une
fois c'est très important
sinon le répèterai pas tout le temps
comme ça les mesures barrières 1 le
masque et ses atouts de la distanciation
sociale on évitera au maximum que les
personnes à risque soit atteinte
c'est ça le but qu'il faudra atteindre
mais il est clair que dans les autres
régions
effectivement le virus ne va pas
disparaître comme ça mais attendez tout
à l'heure vous avez une remarque c'est
que je disais à d'autres facteurs
pour l'instant c'est un nouveau virus ce
virus à quelques mois on le connaît pas
encore parfaitement dieu sait on entend
beaucoup d'inconnues et en particulier
une inconnue c'est une éventuelle
saisonnalité c'est pas impensable
on a on vole on sait que pour les
coronavirus peu grave qui donne lieu à
des rhumes peu important car chez la
famille des coronavirus est connue
depuis un moment maintenant je parle pas
du sarc du maire si bien sûr avant les
corps et on sait que ces virus ont
tendance à disparaître pendant la belle
saison et une saisonnalité hiver
d'hannover re marques dont on verra mais
on peux pas encore le dire ça on le
souhaite et on l'espère on l'espère
fortement avec vous merci pierre salliou
professeur agrégé du val de grâce
d'avoir été avec no mercy de votre de
vos explications direct sur rt france et
autres informations importantes de la
journée elle porte sur le calendrier du
retour à l'école des enfants jean michel
blanquer est rapportée est des
précisions ce matin une rentrée sur
plusieurs semaines par niveau de classe
les plus jeunes étant les premiers
reprend le chemin des courts écoutez les
précisions du ministre l'idée
actuellement est d'abord qu'il ya un
impératif catégorique qui est liée à la
doctrine ciani t1 aux autres alors et
ensuite quiconque travaille par type
définiront quel est le plafond de ces
petits groupes sur un modèle différent
pour l'école primaire et pour lancer
selon m mais un mais se plaint qu'on
pourrait par exemple de 15 élèves et n'y
aurait donc pas une seule classe aurait
plus de 15 élèves pendant cette période
ce qui très souvent reviendra en 1/2
groupe avec une classe existantes
cela signifierait que nous ferions
rentrée à partir du de la semaine les 11
mai et réalité ce ne serait pas le 11
mai lui-même ce qu'il y aurait une pré
rentrée des professeurs de l'école
primaire
mais au cours des jours suivants nous
ferions rentrée les classes de grande
section de cp et de cm2 ensuite on
aurait l'enseignement secondaire en
semaine 2 c'est-à-dire la semaine qui
commence le 18 mai avec le col du
collège pour lesquelles ce serait la
classe de 6ème et la classe de 3e puis
ainsi que le lycée la classe de 1ère et
la classe de terminale il ya enfin le
lycée professionnel pour lesquels on
commencerait par les ateliers
industriels et enfin en semaine 3 l'a25
mais bien l'ensemble des classes
pourrait rentrer mais le système serait
organisé pour que ce soit loin et des
groupes de pas plus de quinze élèves
pour y arriver
l'élève se signer dans quatre situations
possibles soit il est en demi groupe en
présence donc le cas de figure que j'ai
décrit soit il est à distance en tirant
tous les enseignements de la période
actuelle
pour certains élèves qui sont rentrés
chez eux et soir troisième lieu il est à
l'étude si la configuration de
l'établissement le permet là aussi avec
pas plus de quinze élèves
quatrièmement nous proposons que nous
proposerons de manière facultative mais
à toutes les communes d'avoir des
activités sportives à côté de
l'établissement
ça peut être dans un gie nasa peut être
dans un parc si le temps le permet et
c'est dans ce contexte tendu de crise du
cordat virus et de confinement que
nouvelle qui a une nouvelle nuit tension
amina
la garenne dans les hauts de seine
l'accident samedi d'un motard roulant à
vive allure a mis le feu aux poudres
l'homme a eu la jambe fracturée après
avoir percuté la portière d'un véhicule
de police banalisé il a porté plainte
contre x depuis ailleurs se multiplient
avec les forces de l'ordre au total neuf
personnes ont été interpellées dans
l'agglomération parisienne ces dernières
heures
elle des incidents qui ont fait tache
d'huile sur d'autres villes on voit son
image avec ses vidéos amateurs on ne
mord pas
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
j'ai écouté l écho d
du petit caractère
[Applaudissements]
hu
[Musique]
en brèche
[Applaudissements]
nos chiffres au et mathématiques
esch
et pour évoquer les banlieues nous
sommes en direct avec mohamed mechmache
président et membre fondateur du
collectif ac le feu association
collective liberté égalité fraternité
ensemble unis bonsoir mohamed mechmache
merci d'être avec nous on a vu ce choc
on va dire des images sur les réseaux
sociaux est ce que ce sont des incidents
isolés ou faut-il craindre un
embrasement dans les banlieues selon
vous alors bon soir justement rectifié
je suis porte parole du collectif
inculpés et président de la coordination
nationale partant nous voilà alors qui
est au démarrage c'est toujours des cas
isolés
encore une fois on part d'une étincelle
qui concerne la police et des jeunes
donc ça reste isolée ensuite
effectivement ce sentiment d'injustice
ou de l'impunité qui pour certains
policiers encore une fois par l'ensemble
encore tout à fait la distinction au
niveau de notre police tant que j'ai
effectivement je ne rabats sentiment
qu'il ya une justice qui est égal et
qu'il ya une justice à double vitesse
oui effectivement on risque
malheureusement que les choses
dégénèrent et puis à chaque fois on se
retrouve en m a souvent on appelle au
calme ce que je fais déjà dans un
premier temps j'ai une pensée pour la
famille le jeune qui est hospitalisé
aujourd'hui qui risque de perdre une
jambe mais encore une fois je veux dire
il faut qu'à un moment ou un autre déjà
d'une une parole politique qui
clairement 10 et faire en sorte que
toute la lumière sera faite ce qu'ils
apprennent ce pâté et puis on va pas
crier au loup
ce qu'on demande effectivement à ce que
ça ne se propage pas partout en france
comme on a connu en 2001 coup ça a
démarré à clichy-sous-bois la suite à la
lande et zied et bouna 15 ans ram ou les
choses ont pris une mesure une tension
et où ça fait propagées dans toute la
france
donc il faut éviter effectivement kg et
tout ça il faut éviter clairement encore
une fois maintenant il ya les réseaux
sociaux qui circule vite mais que aussi
une médiatique
on focalise là-dessus toi parce que du
coup ça fait un appel d'air alors nous
on essaye en tout cas de comprendre
puisque c'est vrai que certains parlent
de violence contre la police d'autres au
contraire parle de violences policières
c'est compliqué de de s'en sortir qui
doit-on croire que moi je pense que si
on regarde bien ça date pas
d'aujourd'hui
moi je les ai connus déjà à l'époque de
1983 et et certaines bavures policières
avec ces tensions ensuite je pense que
tout le monde a découvert ces violences
suite aux jets les jaunes alors qu'elle
était déjà dénoncée plus ou moins dans
les quartiers populaires donc je sais
pas moi je pense que ces tensions quand
est ce qu'on aura effectivement une
discussion aux polices population parce
que maintenant aujourd'hui tout le monde
est concerné par ce sujet là il va
falloir comme moi honnêtement on pose le
doigt dessus pour qu'on trouve les
solutions pour que ces tensions n'existe
plus quoi on imagine que le confinement
évidemment n'êtes pas y est
également beaucoup de de pauvreté vous
distribuez d'ailleurs vous même de
l'aide alimentaire à clichy sous bois en
seine saint denis est ce que vous êtes
de plus en plus sollicitée ces temps ci
bien sûr je voudrais surtout faire une
réaction parce qu'il y en a beaucoup qui
ont commencé à titrer les violer les
émeutes de la faim
on n'a rien à voir avec la question de
la fois plus de choses dit il ya
justement entière qui se sont passées
suite à à à villeneuve la garenne et il
ya effectivement toute cette question où
ce virus cette tragédie sanitaire est
tout simplement en train de pointer le
bout de son nez sur une crise sociale
parce que toutes ces inégalités qui
existent depuis ces trente dernières
années qui malheureusement n'ont pas
arrêté d'être dénoncé par différentes
associations sont en train de simplement
voir le jour multipliée par dix donc
effectivement on a aujourd'hui tout
simplement différentes populations et
qui vivent dans ces quartiers qui
clairement aujourd'hui seront aussi la
richesse de l'acompte qui
malheureusement ces deux sont des
salariés pauvres pour certains
continuent effectivement à faire partie
de la chaîne qu'on applaudit les aides
soignantes et tous les détails qui font
un travail formidable mais on oublie
aussi ceux qui aujourd'hui font en sorte
que les bureaux soient nettoyer
désinfecter les têtières et chauffeurs
livreurs les chauffeurs de taxi les
éboueurs qui clairement on rôle à jouer
activiste dans ces quartiers-là donc
certains se retrouvent au chômage
certains sont en arrière et à certains
qui malheureusement sont diplômés n'ont
jamais été reconnus pour leurs diplômes
leurs compétences dont qui sont amenés à
faire un boulot qui clairement sont dans
l'obligation d'apporter une nourrir
leurs familles se retrouvent dans des
situations précaires on a des mamans
seules qui permettent des ménages on a
des personnes qui ont essayé de joindre
les deux bourses dans des boulots par ci
par là aux blacks pour combler les fans
mois on a des parents qui aujourd'hui
neteller encore à la cantine qui ne
permettent plus de coeur qui continue à
enfermer
donc ça veut dire plus de personnes dans
des logements
qui sont malheureusement très petit avec
un confinement de huit à neuf personnes
dans des petits logements
on a
justement une charge supplémentaire au
nom en électricité donc ça fait un coût
réel manque à gagner donc aujourd'hui on
a tout simplement pris notre bras notre
bras le problème à bras le corps pour
apporter des réponses assez rapidement à
ce manque à gagner quoi donc c'est tout
ça qu'on fait des distributions
solidaires au niveau de ces familles
merci beaucoup mohamed mechmache
président donc est membre fondateur du
collectif ac le feu d'avoir été avec
nous en direct sur rt français la
lumière des dernières tensions qui ont
éclaté dans certains quartiers des
hauts-de-seine et sur tout le territoire
dans ton craindre un embrasement y at-il
un risque d'émeutes dans ces banlieues
après le 11 mai à la faveur du
déconfinement c'est l'objet de notre
face à face ce soir
[Musique]
dre pour en débattre nous sommes en
direct par skype avec julien odoul
membre du bureau national du
rassemblement national bonsoir julien
odoul merci d'un choc nous à ses côtés à
distance david guiraud porte-parole
jeunesse de la france insoumise merci à
vous d'être là aussi on vient
effectivement de parler de ses
incidences pose la question aujourd'hui
ce sont des actes isolés ou des actes au
contraire que comme l'a évoqué notre
invité précédent qui peuvent mettre le
feu aux poudres on commence par vous
fait les andouilles bas ce ne sont pas
des actes isolés il faut le dire et se
sont d'ailleurs pas que des actes et des
violences contre la police et des
violences contre la france ça fait
depuis trop longtemps que du fait du
laxisme du fait d'avoir totalement
abandonné ses quartiers à la loi des
racailles loi des islamo racaille parce
qu'il faut bien appeler un chat un chat
que ces quartiers font sécession que ces
quartiers considère qu' à d'autres lois
que les lois de la république qui
doivent s'imposer que les services
publics de la république n'ont rien à y
faire
que les policiers que les pompiers que
les ambulanciers que les médecins n'ont
rien à y faire et sont violentés et
caillassés est-ce que nous avons assisté
soit comme mis devant assister hier
avant-hier et donc depuis un stand de
jours c'est tout simplement une
ken de territoire par des banques disent
l'amour à kayes qui n'aiment pas la
france qu'ils ne supportent pas la
france qui ne supporte pas les uniformes
de la république et qui cherche à
imposer leurs règles leurs lois en
cassant en violentant en agressant et ce
sont les policiers évidemment qui sont
les premières victimes de ces
agissements totalement honteux j'ajoute
que le gouvernement elle grande part de
responsabilité d'une pour le laxisme
dont il fait preuve vis-à-vis de ces
criminels de ces délinquants et de deux
puisque depuis le début du confinement
madame bello b à libérer des milliers de
détenus pour renforcer la délinquance
dans ces quartiers totalement
inadmissible c'est une mise en
insécurité des français et la majorité
des habitants de ces quartiers est maire
et vivre en sécurité en france
paisiblement et ne peuvent pas
malheureusement à cause de ces
pourritures ce qui arrive je le trouve
des libyens ou en gardant la récente va
travailler aussi sur cette question
d'image ne venez pas franchement
d'accord avec julien odoul non mais moi
j'suis pas pour la guerre civile en fait
il y en a qui le sont cela c'est leur
avis moi j'ai pas pour la guerre civile
pour la paix je pense qu'il ya beaucoup
de français aujourd'hui qui sont pour la
paix qui le sont dans les quartiers qui
le sont au dehors des quartiers qui
veulent pas voir ces images donc pour la
paix il ya 2 c'est simple enfin va moi
j'assume d'avoir une exigence c'est de
toujours incité mes concitoyens à être
exemplaires a respecté le confinement
parce que c'est une question de sécurité
pour vos proches pour les personnages et
pour les plus fragiles mais on peut même
pas mettre sa dos à dos avec une autre
difficulté c'est que moi j'ai aussi une
autre exigence et chute est naïf mais
j'ai une exigence pour que la justice de
mon pays que la police de mon pays soit
exemplaire et aujourd'hui il ya des
antécédents qui prouve qu'elle ne l'est
pas totalement
on se souvient de personnes décédées
pendant des opérations de police je
pense aux familles et au nom de famille
traoré niang el yamani chaouia au donc
beaucoup de nos qui sont aujourd'hui une
blessure pour les habitants des
quartiers populaires et c'est pas si
vous voulez moi je vois pas en quoi
c'est contradictoire de dire qu' il
n'est pas normal que la suite d'une
opération de police qui sont
authentiques et une verbalisation sur la
voie publique un jeune se retrouve avec
la jambe défoncé voilà et je le dis aux
jeunes mais juste moi je le dis parce
que monsieur oudoul vous quand vous avez
été mis en examen en avril dernier pour
réel pour recel
fonds publics vous étiez bien content à
ce moment là qu'on vous ait pas fracturé
le genou ou qu'on faisait vous fait
perdre un oeil voilà ridicule monsieur
guiraud vous êtes ridicule on prend là
écoutez attendez je vais juste finir
mois sur villeneuve la garenne je ne
sais pas si le commissaire de police etc
ou pas d'accord je pense que la paix
c'est pas aussi dit d'attiser les
braises d'un côté comme de l'autre
ceci dit reconnaissons ensemble de
choses simples
c'est que c'est pas normal que les
gyrophares n'ait pas été mis parce que
quand on interpelle quelqu'un qui roule
vite c'est mieux de mettre les
gyrophares plutôt que de que d'ouvrir sa
portière parce que c'est dangereux et
que de toute façon qu'il l'ait fait
exprès ou pas on est dans une situation
d'échec de l'opération de police voilà
moi ça me semble simple à dire à pau on
va parler tout à l'heure peut-être à
l'ordre social
messieurs en écouter un autre point de
vue puis va je vais vous faire réagir
dessus julien oudoul celui de noah main
noire c'était notre invité hier
policiers délégué du syndicat vigie pour
lui il ya de fausses informations qui
circulent sur les réseaux sociaux pour
provoquer justement des violences
urbaines écoutez il ya des tentatives de
récupérations évidente en fait de cette
affaire il ya effectivement des gens qui
souffle sur les braises
le soir même des événements à peu près
une demi heure après la diffusion des
images
on a des sites d'extrême droite qui ont
diffusé de fausses images d'émeutes de
deux ans les attribuera villeneuve la
garenne pour justement provoqué des
violences urbaines
il semblerait malheureusement que la
jeunesse soit tombé dans le panneau et
se soient laissés entraîner dans cette
logique très gêné en double sur cette
piste de récupération à ce que vous
cautionnez l'extrême droite qui fait
monter la sauce qui met de l'huile sur
le feu mais bien évidemment c'est
l'extrême droite qui aujourd'hui
dévastent le pays c'est l'extrême droite
qui incendient des commissariats aux
cris d'allah akbar c'est l'extrême
droite qui agressent des policiers
évidemment mais il faut être sérieux
restons sérieux
je vais répondre à monsieur guiraud la
personne donc 2
le ce jeune fois dix ans donc qui a eu
la jambe et donc blessé lors de ce
contrôle de police tu sais tu pas un
simple motards c'est une racaille xxl
multirécidiviste qui a été condamné 14
fois cartonné alors pour vous pour ce
super science pour extorsion pour
violences donc arrêter le capacité l'ong
argentine - un enfant de choeur il sait
bien ce à l'heure je vais terminer je
vais terminer je voulais télé c'est
terminé
aujourd'hui il faut bien savoir c'est
dans tous les quartiers de france un
certain nombre de quartiers vous avez
des bandes qui profite de la moindre
étincelle du moindre événement aussi
anodin soit il pour déverser leur haine
de la france pour s'attaquer aux forces
de l'ordre
et pour faire finalement pour imposer un
message est pour dire à la république
qu'ils sont chez eux et que la
république n'a pas à être dans ces
quartiers c'est tout mais non la santé
il faut reconquérir ces quartiers il
faut les reconquérir la plus grande
fermeté à julien on june aurait de la
gueule d'un groupe de personnes
uniquement
finalement non mais attendez moi c'est
que je me de personnes excusez moi c'est
pas c'est pas un groupe de personnes
c'est pas quelques individus isolés on
le voit il ya une trentaine de villes où
des émeutes des guérillas donc ont
émaillé donc ces derniers jours donc
c'est pas un groupe de personnes on voit
bien aujourd'hui qu'il ya des quartiers
entiers
il ya des mêmes des communes entières
qui aujourd'hui ne sont plus sous le
contrôle de l'état de droit
ils sont sous le contrôle de la
république il va falloir les reconquérir
une à une
ah c'est le rôle de l'état républicain
et malheureusement c'est pas avec ce
gouvernement qu'on y arrivera dan didio
lens - moi je suis désolé mais déjà mois
pour moi un discours de paix donc au
fond mais quand il ya des violences par
exemple qu'elle paie et leurs pendants
les gilet jaune vous savez il ya des
violences parfois dans la société
la meilleure manière de régler ces
violences ce n'est pas de traiter les
gens comme des sauvages ou comme des
fous chriqui n'aurais eu aucune raison
de se mettre en colère aujourd'hui à des
tensions sociales dans les quartiers moi
je lui dis qu'une jeune non mais
attendez j'ai raison monsieur niro
leading à monsieur dont je vous ai
laissé parler de nador nautiques de la
ville qui ont été déversées dans ces
quartiers ils sont celles mentionnées
ils sont talonnés par les nominations il
com quelles raisons cool parce que la
raison c'est que le taux de pauvreté est
immensément plus fort en seine saint
denis que dans la plupart des
territoires il ya quelques territoires
ruraux qui sont très pauvres aussi mais
qu'ils consentent moins d'habitants et
n'est donc la subaru rally de cornes le
cas cette fois ci le pr lina
non mais si je peux me permettre de
finir par des mails à avoir un discours
de paix c'est pas ça mais moi la limite
à chaque fois vous parlez vous renforcez
vous renforcez les réactions donc ce
n'est pas très grave mais à la limite
mais je vous dis qu'aujourd'hui il ya
des gamins dans les quartiers qui
étaient hubert qui étaient des libéraux
qui étaient des chauffeurs sur des
métiers très précaire qui aujourd'hui du
fait du confinement n'ont pas d'argent
d'accord ils ne vont probablement pas
avoir de compensations financières
résultant majesty fait violence pour
vous justifie les violences mais non je
ne justifie rien moi j'appelle les gens
à la paix la famille de la victime
appelle les gens à la paix vous savez la
famille de ce monsieur lé plus descendre
que vous la famille d'un homme dial qui
a qui a été gravement blessée la multi
récidiviste à la dea famille d'une ragga
et xxl
non je cours je maigrisse canet
d'hérault genre de marley la fin d'année
moi messieurs vice président
pardonnez-moi jordan dare dare
disposions de votre parti julien houde
où le rassemblement national demande ce
soir justement un couvre-feu dans les
communes concernées par les émeutes
c'est un début de solution pour vous
david guiraud
non non non non moi je vous le dis
aujourd'hui à des hélicoptères moi
j'habite en seine-saint-denis donc ils
hésitent cocktail qui tombe moi je suis
désolé après que cueillait des
opérations de police en ce moment
effectivement parce que c'est très
compliqué ça peut se concevoir mais je
vous dis juste une chose
aujourd'hui vous avez une grande tension
sociale dans les quartiers populaires
qui souffre de deux choses d'une du
signe d'une situation matérielle la
situation de latéral est gelée dit c'est
qu'aujourd'hui vous avez des banques
alimentaires en seine saint denis
notamment parce que les gens ont faim
les gens ne peuvent pas se nourrir dans
certains quartiers normalement il ya des
gamins qui ont faim vous avez des
logements insalubres
quand vous êtes une famille en plus on
le sait en seine-saint-denis les femmes
y sont plus nombreuses qu'en vous êtes
cinq ou six dans 30 35 mètres carrés
c'est très compliqué je préfère le dire
donc ça c'est matériellement et puis
symboliquement vous avez aussi un
traitement de des personnes des
quartiers populaires qui est tout
simplement scandaleux
que oui effectivement c'est ce n'est pas
une bonne chose de faire des rodéos dans
la rue en période de confinement
j'assume de le dire mais par contre la
manière dont on présente ça y compris
dans les médias vous avez mis en avant
mohamed mechmache pense que c'est une
bonne chose c'est un vrai militant des
quartiers populaires qui appelle à la
paix mais quand vous avez après dans les
médias ou des gens comme julio abdul qui
arrive alors que je viens au double au
sien il est mis en débat mais il ya il a
droit à la parole
je vous le dis oui mais je vous dis tout
le monde a droit à deux pâtés de nous
excuser moi votre faim et que tous les
actionnaires au delà la mode la fin ça
se finit juste ça que dans tous les cas
le passé judiciaire de la personne n'est
pas la chose qui est importante dans la
sphère parce que c'est la question de
l'interpellation qui pose problème qu'on
est dans un pays où il ya des protocoles
où il ya des règles sûres selon
lesquelles on interpelle - n'atteint pas
le pas pour pas mettre la vie des gens
en danger à chaque fois qu'il ya un
délit ou quelque chose de ce type là
sinon c'est pas la justice c'est la loi
du talion
mais moi c'est pas ma conception de la
république et j'aimerais que la france
soit aussi exemplaire sur ce point de
vue là je pense que c'est de ce que
demande beaucoup de jeunes pas forcément
se vous savez qui sont aujourd'hui dans
la rue en train de tout casser mais
beaucoup de jeunes qui sont chez eux
qu'ils respectent le confinement et qui
sont eux aussi en colère j'ai rien au
delà le mot de la fin rapide lanceront
vous plaît oui bon je pense qu'il faut
arrêter avec la pleurniche sur les
quartiers sur la politique de la ville
dans la ruralité et j'en suis dans
l'yonne
vous avez d extrême misère vous avez des
gens qui souffrent et ces gens souffrent
en silence et il ne casse pas et le
violente pas et ne vont pas agresser les
forces de l'ordre
et puisqu'on parlait des gilet jaune moi
je m'étonne et je suis surpris que des
déploiements de violence qui ont et
d'état qui ont été déversées contre les
gilets jaunes destinés à des
manifestants pacifiques ne soit pas
aujourd'hui consacrés au maintien de
l'ordre est la reconquête républicaine
dans les quartiers se sont plaints
magasins dont on voit pas
d'interpellations musclées
là on voit pas de drones que là on va
pas de journalistes qui s'élève à
grenoble on aimerait que tous les moyens
soient mis en oeuvre pour rétablir
l'ordre dans ces quartiers qui sont
aussi je le répète la france merci
messieurs merci julien merci à vous
david guiraud d'avoir été avec nous pour
débattre de ces tensions dans les
banlieue en pleine crise donc dû
coronavirus merci à tous les deux et
cette crise au du corona virus et ses
conséquences sur les prix du baril les
etats-unis ont vécu hier une chute
spectaculaire du cours du pétrole
trop d'offre déstockage saturé résultat
après deux mois de chute la valeur du
baril coté à new york hier soir
en dessous du zéro dollar du jamais vu
dans le pays
en clair les investisseurs ont cherché à
se débarrasser de leurs barils au point
d'être prêts à payer pour trouver
preneur
mais la population elle est divisée
certaines personnes ne cachent pas leur
inquiétude quant à une hausse soudaine
tandis que d'autres semblent bien
accueillir cette chute écouter pour nous
c'est un rêve
il y a moins de voitures l'essence est
moins cher c'est fou oui je veux dire ça
va augmenter parce que ça ne peut pas
rester comme ça alors je suis sûr qu'ils
vont arrêter de produire ou quelque
chose comme ça réduire la production
pour que les prix augmentent avec vous à
long terme c'est très mauvais pour
l'économie car le pétrole devraient être
stables ils devraient être au moins à 50
70 dollars pas comme maintenant ça
ressemble plutôt aux années 20 mais cela
nuira à l'économie à tous les autres pas
seulement ici tient la mondialisation
mieux c'est je pense que cela est non
seulement l'environnement mais ça nous
rend aussi plus indépendant nous avons
été sous l'emprise du pétrole pendant
bien trop longtemps
et bien selon moi cela signifie que nous
pouvons gagner plus d'argent si c'est
moins cher nous pouvons faire plus de
profits c'est évident je ne sais pas
pour le reste du monde mais c'est bon
pour nous je n'ai pas beaucoup de
sympathie pour les maniaques du pétrole
de toute façon alors oui c'est bon pour
nous mais pour évoquer cette crise nous
sommes avec olivier delamarche
économistes bonsoir olivier delamarche
partie
d'être avec nous un cours du pétrole qui
a chuté hier sous la barre des 0 $ on a
dû peines pénales croire un niveau
jamais atteint jamais atteint par don
jusque là votre réaction
bonsoir bah écoute et leur réaction
s'est fait assez amusé parce que j'ai
l'impression que personne n'a compris en
fait qui s'était passé
c'était simplement les futures qui était
à l'échéance
lundi soir et donc vous aviez plein de
nouveaux investisseurs qui se sont
retrouvés lundi en pleine panique parce
qu'il avait acheté le baril sur les
futures qui se terminait il avait acheté
le baril
et tout d'un coup on leur a annoncé que
on allait leur livrer des barils et
évidemment le petit trader dans son
studio de 20 mètres carrés si vous
voulez qui c'est qui tout d'un coup
c'est dit qu' il allait avoir deux mille
barils chez lui ça l'a un peu affolés et
donc il a vendu et il a vendu à ce
moment là à n'importe quel prix mais il
faut bien différencier deux choses le
pétrole physique qui lui de cuillé un
but en est vendu déjà largement en
dessous de 20 dollars suivant d'où il
vient
d'accord et le ce qui se passe sur les
marchés financiers qui est en quelque
chose de purement technique si vous
voulez donc et on a bien vu à ce moment
là que par exemple brent n'a pas suivi
pourquoi pourquoi le brent laing pas
suivi tout simplement parce que le brent
vous pouvez à l'échéance des futures sur
le brent
vous pouvez être réglé en cash ou être
réglé en pétrole le wti en revanche vous
n'avez pas le choix
vous êtes automatiquement régler en
pétrole dont qui évidemment vous avez
des gens qui ont paniqué totalement qui
sont trouvés potentiellement
livré en pétrole et ça il voulait pas on
peut les comprendre et à ce moment là
ils ont vendu massivement et on se
retrouve avec un futur pétrole 1 au tf
de pétrole qui aujourd'hui n'a pas coté
et je pense que ça va faire des pertes
gigantesques chez les courtiers
chez les banquiers qui ont spéculé sur
le sur le pétrole et les prix du baril à
côté de vous couper parce que au moment
où je vous parle le prix du baril coté à
new york est repassé en clôture
au-dessus de 0 à 10 dollars est ce que
ça veut dire que vous êtes en train de
nous on tient finalement c'est un
micro-événement techniques auxquelles on
apporte aux événements mais bien sûr que
c'est un micro événement c'est à dire
que vous avez 7 cette échéance des
futures mais si si vous alliez le même
jour hier
vous vouliez acheter du pétrole vous
alliez le payer plus de 20 dollars le
baril sur l'échéance de juin
donc arrêtons de se prendre la tête là
dessus ce qui est vrai en revanche c'est
économiquement
aujourd'hui le pétrole vous le payez sur
des sur des zones qui sont extrêmement
basses et que ça ça va on je pense que
ça va dans les mois qui viennent
complètement détruire tout le pétrole de
schiste aux états unis pourquoi tout
pétrole de schiste aux états unis tout
simplement parce que le pétrole de
schiste c'est un pétrole qui coûte cher
à sortir du sol
vous avez des coûts de production qui
ont qui sont entre 50 et 70 dollars le
baril et donc quand vous sortez quelque
chose du sort à 70 dollars le baril et
que vous le vendez 20 évidemment ça fait
mal ça fait très très mal et donc vous
avez tous le tout le pétrole de schiste
qui est en train de faire faillite
avec tout l'écosystème qui avait autour
de ce pétrole de schiste qui sont
les devil quasiment entière qui se sont
construites autour des puits de pétrole
et ti aujourd'hui avec tous les services
qui sont associés et qui aujourd'hui
vont faire faillite
on a constaté une forte augmentation des
banques régionales des feuilles de
banques régionales aux états unis qui
sont celles qui avaient prêté au pétrole
de schiste et je vous dis là aujourd'hui
le l'événement d'hier va faire très
probablement des gros trous d'eau chez
des courtiers
chez des traders est aussi probablement
dans des banques mais ça on le saura que
dans quelques que dans quelques mois
mais là c'est un événement qui est
purement financier qui concerne en rien
ce qui se passe sur le pétrole physique
en revanche elle pétrole physique
aujourd'hui on sait qu'on en a en
surabondance qu'on ne sait plus où
mettre que vous avez aujourd'hui les
stocks terrestres qui sont pleins à ras
bord et que on emploie depuis un certain
nombre de semaines
les tanks air qui sont au pont qui font
des ronds dans l'eau pour stocker le
pétrole merci malheureusement s'il
voulait plus on a un pétrole qui est bas
plus on va avoir un problème de stockage
merci d'avoir est avec nous verser pour
vos explications olivier delamarche en
direct sur rt france et la crise du
coronavirus chez nos voisins européens
présents le royaume uni déplore près de
830 morts supplémentaires en 24 heures
le nombre de décès dus au courant d'un
virus qui repart donc à la hausse au
total plus de 17000 300 victimes du
commis 19 outre manche
et ce alors qu'un petit nombre d'élus
est retourné au parlement aujourd'hui
une séance qui s'est déroulée en
visioconférence avec des députés
confinés chez eux
winchester ne peut accueillir en effet
que 50 personnes sur les 650 membres qui
le composent
et puis en espagne légère hausse du
nombre de morts aujourd'hui avec 430
décès dans les dernières 24 heures il
était 2 399 hier par ailleurs le conseil
des ministres a approuvé nouvelle
prolongation jusqu'au 9 mai inclus de
l'état d'alerté du confinement décrété
un confinement qui sera légèrement
assoupli à partir de lundi prochain pour
permettre aux enfants de moins de 14 ans
accompagnés d'un adulte de les
accompagner lors de sorties par exemple
autorisé au supermarché ou à la
pharmacie le danemark à présent qui lève
également progressivement ces
restrictions les crèches et les écoles
maternelles primaires ont ouvert le 15
avril déjà
mais le gouvernement annonce qu'il
n'autorisera aucun rassemblement de plus
de cinq cents personnes avant le 1er
septembre depuis lundi c'est au tour de
certains commerces de rouvrir leurs
portes les précisions avec claire nico
un mois que les coiffeurs et bardier
n'avait pas pu ouvrir leurs salons
depuis lundi ils peuvent enfin
accueillir de nouveau leurs clients à
condition par contre de respecter
quelques règles d'hygiène
il y a des gants jetables ils sont
spécialement fabriqués sont achetés
comme des fournitures de coiffure
[Musique]
utilisons des masques pour la bouche
nous désinfecte toi un peu plus le
ciseau et nos peines
nous utilisons un produit appelé
barbotte side il s'agit d'un acides
dilués dans lequel vous pouvez placer
dépeignent les accessoires de coûts
après les avoir utilisés sur un client
salon de coiffure dentiste
psychothérapeute ou encore salon de
tatouage peuvent pour le rouvrir leurs
portes depuis le 20 avril au danemark le
pays entre eux pointent déconfinement
progressif mais les établissements
doivent obligatoirement se conformer aux
nouvelles réglementations strictes en
matière d'hygiène édictées par le
gouvernement danois pour empêcher une
nouvelle propagation du court aux
navires us des règles qui pour certaines
professions ne diffère pas forcément des
précautions prises avant la pandémie ce
tablier en plastique est différent nous
ne l'avons pas utiliser avant le corona
virus pendant la crise nous l'avons
utilisée lorsque nous avions des
patients aiguë mais sinon c'est très
similaire à avant nous portons
maintenant une visière ou nous
utilisions paravent des lunettes
ordinaire pour nous protéger les yeux du
côté des écoles la première ministre
danoise m frédéric scène à
d'annoncer une levée progressive des
restrictions en vigueur le 15 avril
dernier la moitié des crèches écoles
maternelles et écoles primaires du pays
avait donc déjà rouvert depuis lundi
c'est l'ensemble de ces établissements
qui sont concernés un retour à la
scolarité sous certaines conditions
lavage de mains obligatoire à l'arrivée
des élèves puis au moins toutes les deux
heures les escaliers ne pourront être
utilisés qu'à sens unique
les classes seront divisés en 2 ou 3 et
les gymnases réfectoire ateliers ou
salles de sciences seront réquisitionnés
pour servir de classes et ainsi
respecter deux mètres entre chaque
bureau d'écolier
je pense que c'est la seule chose à
faire ou nous n'aurons jamais
l'infection se contrôler il est
également nécessaire que nous
commencions à emmener les enfants à la
garderie
sinon c'est difficile de travailler
comme vous ne pouvez pas vous rendre au
travail
il s'agit donc de relancer une vie
normale agréable et facile et de
respecter toutes les règles d'hygiène
une réouverture progressive qui ne
touche pas encore le secondaire les
collèges et les lycées recommenceront eu
à accueillir des élèves à partir du 10
mai prochain et pour en parler nous
sommes avec cubaine tran rollmann alice
politique bonsoir à ebay notre album
alors on est évidemment très intéressé
par ce qui se passe au danemark parce
que vous avez un petit peu une longueur
d'avancé sur la france il faut bien le
dire comment se se déroule ce
déconfinement progressif chez vous sont
assez déprimée et je suis désolé de
devoir le dire je pense que les gens
sont un peu perturbé se demande qui peut
se décliner et qui restent confinés les
petites classes à l'école sont ouvertes
les coiffeurs également et les boutiques
de tatouages les dix personnes ils
peuvent pas se rassembler
et hier professeur le directeur d'un
organe des sanitaires qui est conseille
le gouvernement a dit qu'il faudrait
peut-être maintenir la distanciation
sociale pendant plus d'un an
c'était au temps pour les gens la
première ministre a rencontré les autres
partis politiques aujourd'hui c'est les
parties nous demander si lens était prêt
si cela pourrait durer jusqu'à un an
sans retrouver la vie normale et elle a
dit qu'elle ne pouvait pas le dire que
personne ne pouvait dire car seule la
lumière attire et s'il y aurait une
seconde vague se traîne donc pas
beaucoup d'hésitation mais on ne sait
pas ce qui va arriver c'est la grande
question que va-t-il se passer car il ya
eu ces réouvertures l'occe mais l'avenir
reste encore très vagues ne savons pas
ce qui va arriver au long terme
alors ce qu'ils sont cocasses et
qu'effectivement vous nous dites dix
personnes ne peuvent pas se rassembler
dans le même temps les écoles et les
crèches rouvre on l'a vu progressivement
quelle est la réunion réaction pardon
des danois
de plus en plus critique à leurs
questions car ils ne comprennent pas
pourquoi les coiffeurs les écoles sont
sous couvert alors ne pas se rassembler
à plus de 10 personnes
effectivement c'est déroutant sims like
et on dirait qu'il n'ya pas de raisons
sanitaires qu'il s'agit plutôt de
décision politique
s'agissant de qui ont bénéficié et qui
ne peut pas beaucoup à un aigle aux
propriétaires
benarrous shops de commerce de nanterre
alors que tout commençait à se faire à
nouveau très tôt et ça n'est pas si
important même si beaucoup de terrain
passe toujours un toyoda que le
gouvernement a pris les bonnes décisions
plus en plus des bars mais cependant une
question pourquoi moi et pas un autre
merci beaucoup et peintres harold de
nous avoir fait un panorama de la
situation au danemark
merci à vous et aux états unis à présent
principal foyer mondial de l'épidémie le
corona virus a tué près de quarante deux
mille personnes près de 800000 4
contamination ont été détectés les
répercussions économiques de la crise
sanitaire sont brutales dans le pays au
moins en moins d'un mois 22 millions
d'américains se sont inscrits à
l'assurance chômage dans ce contexte
donald trump veut relancer l'économie le
président américain qui s'apprête à
signer un décret présidentiel il
pourrait suspendre dès les prochains
jours l'immigration sur le sol américain
la danse surprise a été faite sur
twitter à moins de sept mois de
l'élection présidentielle
à la lumière de la tacc de l'ennemi
invisible ainsi que de la nécessité de
protéger les emplois de nos grands
citoyens américains
je vais signer un décret pour suspendre
temporairement l'immigration aux états
unis elle pourra revenir sur la
suspension temporaire de l'immigration
notamment nous sommes en direct depuis
atlanta avec ben swan journaliste
d'investigation c'est notre rubrique vu
de l'extérieur ce soir
[Musique]
bonsoir ben soit merci d'être avec nous
en direct sur rt france la fermeture des
frontières pour tous ceux qui ne sont
pas citoyens ou résidents américains
pas étonnant quand on connaît un petit
peu la politique de donald trump comment
ça a été accueilli aux états unis cela a
été perçu très différemment en fonction
des rues mieux politique c'est comme ça
elle perd du temps dans ce pays donald
trump a dit qu'il souhaitait interrompre
toute immigration tout quelques endroits
que ce soit donc non seulement de la
chine et de l'europe et il ya une raison
pour cela et je vais développer plus
tard que il s'agit de faire la cour aux
travailleurs et ses immigrants prennent
des emplois alors que beaucoup
d'américains en sont maintenant au
chômage donc que les démocrates les
personnes à gauche sont contre cette
idée et les personnes à droite les
partisans de trump sont départis son
tour et puis il ya ensuite les
indépendants les voteurs qu'on ne vote
pas pour départissent thématiquement et
de ce point de vue là ça dépend de là où
ils prennent leurs informations parce
que des gens disent c'est une très
mauvaise idée de ces jeunes quand on
sait qu'il ya des millions à 22 millions
d'américains qui ont perdu leur emploi
qu'on est à quelques mois de l'élection
présidentielle
est ce que cette carte identitaire n'est
pas la meilleure chose
finalement c'est la provocation mais
question mais enfin vous pouvez faire
donald trump dans ce contexte
électoralement parlant bien sûr je pense
que toutes les stratégies sont
politiques en ce moment et c'est vrai au
congrès shell démocrates et républicains
a quasiment le président mène sa
campagne quand il doit être certain que
toutes ces décisions
sont bonnes pour ses électeurs et que
les haters soit content de ce que fait
le président de ce qu'il gère donc c'est
pour cela qu'ils flattent les personnes
qui protestent contre les le confinement
dans beaucoup d'états ont dit à ses
électeurs vous voulez travailler les
gouverneurs devrait vous écoutez ce
n'est peut-être pas forcément le
meilleur conseil mais en tout cas cela
mais le président du côté du peuple et
non pas du côté du gouvernement
c'est très inhabituel de voir un
président qui se place à côté de genève
plutôt que à côté du parlement du
gouvernement qu'il dirige donc c'est
nouveau mais revoir ce que ça donne
effectivement donald trump qui a une
façon bien à lui de gérer cette crise du
coronavirus a été l'un des premiers à
fermer ses frontières maintenant ils
poussent certains états républicains à
ceux des confiné allant à l'encontre
d'ailleurs des gouverneurs poussant même
les gens allaient manifester commencé
perçu outre atlantique ces décisions
parce qu'on sait qu'en ce moment les
manifester c'est pas forcément la bonne
idée en termes de distanciation sociale
effectivement les manifestations met pas
au niveau de la distanciation sociale
mais il ya beaucoup de questions
concernant l'efficacité de ces mesures
la question la plus importante reste
économique et je ne veux pas dire que le
strict où les grandes entreprises
c'est à ce à quoi pensent certaines
personnes mais je parle des petits
propriétaires ceux qui n'ont pas de
salaire qui n'ont pas de salaire depuis
maintenant plusieurs semaines et qui
attendent encore les aides
gouvernementales
ces personnes sont très inquiètes niveau
de l'économie s'ils demandent ce qui va
se passer à l'avenir et rêve à l'amiable
très proche donc nous assistons à un
mécontentement grandissant 30 à 35 % des
américains jolie feinte illégale du
confinement
c'est une deux ou trois semaines
écoeuré y avoir encore plus de
mécontentement et on pourrait imaginer
que
le personnes changerait d'opinion 15h et
du mind raymond famille ben soit comment
cette crise du coronavirus pestel dans
cette campagne de l'élection
présidentielle on rappelle un cent
quatre-vingt dix sept jours avant
l'élection ses prises de décisions de
donald trump mais aussi on imagine une
campagne des républicains des pardons
des démocrates assez inaudibles c'est
typique je pense que nous allions à un
moment de son bail
le président organise des conférences de
presse mais il essaye de se positionner
comme dirigeant déterminé ce n'est pas
vraiment une véritable campagne il n'a
pas pu se rendre dans les états comme
d'habitude et joe biden qui est le
candidat démocrate essaye de tenir des
réunions depuis sa cave depuis son s'il
y a un côté positif pour le peuple
américain c'est qu'on n'est pas obligé
de me voir infliger une campagne en
profondeur elle est un peu équipe s'est
mise de côté
peut-être qu'au cours des semaines et
des mois à venir il y aura une véritable
campagne les pour le mans il ya une
sorte de calme et c'est très positif
la plupart des gens en ce moment ne
veulent pas entendre parler de politique
ils veulent entendre
ils veulent savoir ce que le
gouvernement va faire pour les aider
merci beaucoup de soin à une journaliste
d'investigation d'avoir été avec nous
dans vu de l'extérieur ce soir donc
quelques instants rester avec nous dont
viendront évidemment sur cette crise du
cornât virus en france près de 21 mille
personnes sont décédées depuis le début
de l'épidémie puis nous parlerons de ce
top cow vie de l'application mobile de
traçage des données dans la lutte contre
l'épidémie il sera finalement soumise à
un vote des députés le 28 avril
enfin nous irons au luxembourg le
luxembourg qui a entamé son
déconfinement et rend le port du masque
obligatoire
d
[Musique]
là
ici on écoute ceux qui ne sont pas
d'accord
[Musique]
ici on invite les plus compétents pas
seulement ceux qui parlent le plus fort
[Musique]
ici on reçoit c'est qu'on me vois pas
ailleurs
[Musique]
alors ce qui si seul interdit
d'interdire
[Musique]
cette crise qui n'est pas je vous
rappelle qu'une crise de santé publique
c'est malheureusement devenu une crise
économique majeure tous les pays
européens se sont repliés sur eux mêmes
et ont joué leur carte sans s'occuper de
ce qui se passait ailleurs est ce qui
veut dire que les états gardent donc ait
la main-mise sur leur politique de santé
est ce qu'il faudrait peut-être revoir
un peu hâlé statut il faudrait que les
états aient réellement la main
aujourd'hui en règle à nouveau un
problème économique par de la dette
ça vous aliens c'est ça vous ça donne
les clés de chez vous soit aux banquiers
soit l'état maintenant il n'ya pas il ya
même plus débat
on sait que l'union européenne est mort
oh
depuis le début de cette crise les
français sont dans le flou avec des
informations contradictoires
quelles en sont les conséquences
psychologiquement la peur quand même
socio économique c'est à dire qu'il ya
quand même une détresse socio économique
très très fortes notamment pour pour les
actifs bien évidemment plus vous êtes
âgé plus vous avez peur du réel de la
mort c'est évident les études elle
montre que oui pourquoi 30 à 40%
il y à un stress modéré il ya un stress
sévère pour à peu près 5%
on a un focus assez fort sur les
adolescents étonnamment un focus sur les
aînés également très important c'est à
dire que ceux qui résisteront le mieux
ce sont entre guillemets la classe d
actifs
est ce que ce nom vous l'être humain
peut gérer une proximité quotidienne
avec sa famille comme c'est le cas
aujourd'hui est-ce que ça resserre les
liens vous contraire à ce que ça les
haltères veut nous devons réapprendre le
goût du comportement collectif voilà le
goût un peu d' une autodiscipline le
bout du civisme parce que si nous vivons
ça simplement comme une restriction de
nos libertés individuelles comme si nous
ne vivons pas ça comme une aventure
collective de protection solidaire des
ans a été jeune
ça va être la extraordinairement
[Musique]
bonsoir à tous merci de nous rejoindre
pour une demi heure d'information il est
21h heure de paris tout de suite les
titres de l'actualité de ce mardi 5 7%
des français auront été infectés par le
coronavirus au 11 mai selon des
estimations de l'institut pasteur
loin de l'immunité collective souhaité
par les autorités et qui permettrait
d'éviter une deuxième vague de
contamination
jean-michel bancaire lui annonce une
rentrée en trois étapes 1 le tracking le
traçage et données mobiles dans la lutte
contre le coronavirus il sera finalement
bien soumis à un vote à l'issue du débat
à l'assemblée prévue le 28 avril
tout comme le déconfinement progressif
un scrutin qui n'aura pas de force
contraignante mais dont le gouvernement
pourra difficilement faire fi en cas de
vote majoritairement défavorables plus
de 106 mille morts en europe dont près
de 22000 en espagne qui connaît un léger
rebond du décès duo kobe 19 en 24 heures
d'autres pays du vieux continent
notamment en début de semaine un
déconfinement progressif comme
l'allemagne la norvège ou le luxembourg
le port du masque obligatoire accompagne
bien souvent ces retours à une liberté
relative
[Musique]
la france déplore donc près de 21 mille
décès dus aux coronavirus annonce du
directeur général de la santé jérôme
salomon peu avant 20 heures le solde
d'admissions à l'hôpital demeure négatif
avec 478 personnes hospitalisées en
moins par rapport à hier le nombre de
personnes en réanimation baisse lui
aussi pour le 13e jour consécutif
117 1324 cas serait confirmée selon les
estimations de santé publique france les
données hospitalières font l'objet de
remontées quotidienne de 1300 un
établissement de santé
trente mille cent six personnes sont
actuellement hospitalisés pour une
infection coheed 1885 nouveaux patients
ont été hospitalisés
ces dernières 24 heures mais en tenant
compte des sorties le solde reste
négatif avec 478 personnes hospitalisées
en moins par rapport à hier 5433
patients dans un état grave
nécessite une hospitalisation en
réanimation au cours des dernières 24
heures 190 nouveaux malades ont été
admis dans un service de soins intensifs
de soins continus ou de réanimation le
solde reste négatif
voilà le 13e jour consécutif il est de
250 patients en moins en réanimation
dans les outre-mer on relève 81,18
hospitalisation c'est une baisse de 10
admission de 32 patients en réanimation
là aussi le chiffre baisse doucement un
débat houleux ont vu au parlement les 28
et 29 avril prochain puisque le tracking
fera l'objet d'un vote
cette application de traçage numérique
voulue par le gouvernement se heurte à
plusieurs problèmes pas seulement sur
les questions de vie privée mais aussi
sur les aspects techniques les
explications de david camif a renié ses
libertés individuelles pour assurer sa
santé voilà tout l'objet du débat un
débat qui devrait s'intensifier ces
prochains jours au sein de l'assemblée
nationale
puisqu'un vote va avoir lieu une avancée
considérable quand on se
souvient des propos de christophe
castaner fin mars concernant le trafic
cela n'est pas la culture française je
fais confiance aux français pour que
nous n'ayons pas à mettre en place ces
systèmes qui au fond atteignent la
liberté individuelle de chacun pour être
efficace donc ce n'est pas un sujet sur
lequel nous travaillons
dix jours après cette déclaration
finalement le ministre de l'intérieur
laisse entendre que cet outil pourrait
faire partie des solutions retenues par
le gouvernement s'il est soutenu par
l'ensemble de la population une réponse
certainement à ce sondage de
l'université britannique d'oxford
il montre que huit français sur dix
seraient favorables à l'utilisation
d'une application enregistrant leurs
interactions sociales et les avertissant
s'ils ont été en contact avec une
personne malade ducobu 19 ou prévenant
ceux qui l'ont côtoyé s'ils sont
infectés
nous y voilà presque un mois plus tard
l'application stop qu'ovide est prévu
pour accompagner le déconfinement à
partir du 11 mai mais plusieurs
problèmes vont se poser tout d'abord ça
soulève des questions sur les libertés
individuelles
le droit à l'anonymat le secret médical
le libre consentement la gestion des
données collectées sur l'efficacité du
tracking aussi il ya débat directement
liée au nombre d'utilisateurs
ce sera sur la base du volontariat on ne
soutiendra jamais des mesures
coercitives
concrètement dans cette phase de
déconfinement si vous l'acceptez pas ce
que vous pensez que c'est un rôle
citoyen vous vous inscrivez sur une
plateforme qui fonctionne par bluetooth
le bluetooth et la plus grande
contrainte technique à laquelle le
gouvernement fait face et c'est ce qui
pourrait faire tomber à l'eau ce projet
à d'applications la raison apple
interdit depuis plusieurs années sur ces
appareils
l'activation du bluetooth par défaut
l'exemple de singapour est privilégiée
par le gouvernement
le pays a adopté cette technique mais
pas forcément ses habitants puisque
seulement 15 % de la population à
télécharger l'application
il est clair dans les conditions
actuelles que l'application stop covit
nécessiterait d'être ouvert et active en
permanence apple devra donc faire des
concessions qui est loin d'être gay si
apple n'accepte pas de modifier ses
critères techniques
l'application que nous construisons avec
nos partenaires européens notamment
allemands suisses et bientôt italien
onglets et monégasques ne sera jamais
prête pour lyon
mais et sans l'aide d'apple tout autre
solution qui ne passerait pas par la
modification des conditions de
fonctionnement de leur appareil serait
une espèce de bricolage pour éviter ce
bricolage des négociations sont en cours
entre le gouvernement et le géant
américain
de son côté apple tente d'avancer sur
une solution de sortie en étroite
collaboration avec google alliance
inédite qui pourrait résoudre ce
problème
quoi qu'il en soit ce problème technique
met en exergue la question de fond qui
se joue derrière le tracking le respect
de la vie privée et des libertés
individuelles et pour en parler nous
sommes avec un thomas forêt pdg de walt
heures merci d'être avec nous thomas
fort et le tracking déjà soumis au vote
des députés c'est une bonne chose selon
vous alors déjà je crois qu'il faut
faire la distinction entre le tracking
et le lte racing parce qu'on ne parle
pas tracking le tracking ce sont des
données qui sont collectées et qui
remonte aux serveurs généralement des
gens qui les collecte c'est à dire
évidemment les serveurs de google de
facebook et c'est là nous par
apparemment de fufu l'air avoir
effectivement on parle beaucoup de
tracking notamment ce qui s'est passé en
corée du sud
donc vous vous dites on doit parler de
tracking on parle de tracy parce que
ceux dont on tombe assez de la
communication d'un smartphone à un autre
smartphone et ces données là ne vont pas
remonter sur les ions n'importe quel
serveur ça c'est très important que nos
concitoyens comprennent cela déjà ça
réduit et ça répond beaucoup à la
problématique d'exploitation de données
de de vie privée c'est à dire puisque
ces données là ne remonteront pas et
bien sûr il s'agit dans l'incertain sa
session la forêt j'allais pardonnez moi
de vous couper mais c'est très important
parce que c'est là que le bât blesse si
je peux me permettre
quelles sont les garanties que ça ne
remonte pas les garanties évidemment
elles doivent se voir juridiquement avec
les constructeurs et puis surtout avec
les développeurs
alors évidemment que ce soit android à
les systèmes google ou à
les développeurs ça peut être n'importe
qui donc on sait qu quel protocole nous
allons développer
d'ailleurs les européens ont travaillé
sur un protocole ouvert qui s'appelle
robert comme le prénom et qui permet de
s'assurer évidemment que les données
elles sont bien protégés d'une part et
utile ce que je voudrais dire aussi
c'est que l'application qui a été
déployée en asie dont vous parlez elle
s'est heurtée à la même problématique du
bluetooth et elle le permet elle permet
de fonctionner uniquement si les
applications mobiles et tout faire c'est
ça le problème est donc ça fonctionne
que pendant une demi-heure maximum
or là nous parlons d'applications
mobiles qui devraient fonctionner
évidemment sans activation de l'appli
mobile c'est à dire en ce qu'on
l'appelle en bac ça veut dire bon vous
avez votre téléphone fermer
l'application doit fonctionner ça doit
fonctionner parce que ça doit tracer
tous les gens vous rencontrez qui ont
cette même application pendant quinze
jours on parlait d' apple le rôle
d'apple est déterminant manifestement on
a besoin d'eux du géant américain pour
faire un marché cette application ça
veut dire en quelque sorte qu'on est
extrêmement dépendants d'apple
on est évidemment dépendant énormément
des technologies et c'est pas seulement
d'apple alors le problème qu'il faut
bien comprendre pourquoi apple bloque ça
c'est pas pour nous embêter un apple
bloque le déclenchement du bluetooth
parce qu'ils ont une politique de
maîtrise de leurs produits si du jour la
main il autorise que n'importe quelle
application mobile ou celles ci puissent
consommer du bluetooth en permanence
savard a dit radicalement faire baisser
l'autonomie des smartphones des iphone
ça veut dire que s'il autorise ça ils
s'exposent potentiellement un buzz
négatif où tout le monde va constater
que la l'autonomie des smartphones est
bien avec cette application mobile elle
va tenir rien ça va être quelques heures
et puis votre smartphone y sera vide et
ça c'est très important et donc à mon
avis la question que se posent apple
aujourd'hui c'est la question de l'image
qui vont renvoyer si jamais il autorise
ça c'est pas une mauvaise volonté
politique évidemment un
on peut évidemment penser que
l'entreprise américaine ait envie
d'aider sur sur l'épidémie sur bon mais
c'est une vraie problématique
technologique et là une somme face
probablement à une barrière
technologique et c'est pour cela qu'en
quelques jours
à mon sens c'est très peu probable que
nous arrivions à passer cette barrière à
moins qu'apple accepte et communiquent
peut-être en avance sur ce sujet accepte
d'avoir une moins bonne image sur
l'autonomie de ces appareils donc ça
c'est pour la partie technique
évidemment sont souvent mis en avant les
problèmes de droit à l'anonymat de
gestion des données collectives vous en
avait déjà parlé il empêche 8 français
sur 10 semble être favorable vous
comprenez ces français qui sont prêts à
donner finalement des renseignements sur
leur vie privée a brisé le secret
médical pour peut-être le bien public le
bien collectif de la santé à public mais
aussi peut-être pour plus de liberté
pour eux oui je pense que les français
comprennent et écoute ce qu'on veut ce
qu'on leur explique alors évidemment
c'est un sujet compliqué on essaye de
les les simples
mais je crois que le travail de cédric
haut et d'olivier ferrand est évidemment
un travail sérieux il faut il faut
savoir construire les choses parce que
si nous ne faisons rien si nous ne
faisons que nous opposer à la
technologie parce qu'elle nous fait peur
elle nous dépassera et c'est ça c'est
évident les français eux oui pense que
l'utile usage de la technologie peut
être bien fait mais il ya aussi
probablement un peu d'ignorance et et
c'est la raison pour laquelle ce débat à
l'assemblée nationale est très important
même s'il est consultatif c'est très
important de présenter devant la
représentation nationale ce sujet qui
évidemment n'est pas du tracking on ne
parle pas des sujets évoqués auparavant
permise à l'intérieur et qui parlait de
la reconnaissance spatiale on n'est pas
du tout sur ces sujets on est vraiment
sur 13 aucune donnée qui va remonter ça
c'est très important sur la base du
volontariat également c'est très
important ça n'est pas contraignant et
en même temps il faut être attentif au
fait que voilà cette application mobile
ou n'importe quelle technologie déployée
dans un temps de crise
peut-être ne transforme pas aussi
l'avenir quand ce ne sera plus la crise
1 il faut toujours être attentif petite
dernière question rapide il semblerait
que ce système devienne obligatoire en
italie avec le système immunitaire est
ce que vous avez d'autres informations
sur le chemin que prennent les italiens
non mais j'ai pas d'information sur ce
chemin qui prennent n'hésitez rien je
pense que que ce soit obligatoire voilà
c'est une possibilité mais attention je
pense que la voix française sur la base
du volontariat qui de même une voie plus
sage
il s'agit pas d'aller forcer les choses
de toute façon c'est chacun chacun va
devoir s'il utilise chaque volontaire va
devoir déclarer si oui ou non il est
porteur du virus où il a été porteur du
virus
voilà ça ça va être évidemment très
important
les modèles scientifiques parce que
c'est quand même nouveau ce genre de ce
genre d'applications mobiles elle n'a
jamais été testée en réalité montre ses
modèles montrent qu'une année jusqu'à 2
p
sun par exemple dans une ville qu'il
installe permettent de réduire la
transmission du virus déjà auprès d'une
personne donc ce que l'on voit c'est que
voilà 6 600 personnes s'y met ou 1000
personnes vous auriez que 500 qui
probablement attraperont - le coc vite
voilà tout simplement par les
informations ça je pense que c'est très
important et je pense que la techno peut
aider merci beaucoup thomas forêt pdg de
wever d'avoir été avec nous le conseil
d'état rejette la demande de masques a
formulé par les barreaux de paris et de
marseille requête qui vise et le premier
ministre la garde des sceaux et le
ministre de la santé
la juridiction suprême estimant qu'il
n'appartient pas à l'état je cite
d'assumer le bon fonctionnement des
services publics dont il a la charge
selon le conseil d'état l'absence de
l'imf tribution de masse ne constitue
pas une atteinte aux libertés
fondamentales
il n'apparaît pas que l'absence de
distribution de masques de protection
aux avocats lors des entretiens de garde
à vue dans les commissariats aux
comparutions immédiates et plus
généralement là où la présence d'un
avocat est requise auprès d'un
justiciable pour l'exercice des droits
de la défense révélé une carence portant
de manière caractériser une atteinte
grave et manifestement illégale aux
libertés fondamentales et pour caroline
mécary avocate au barreau de paris le
conseil d'état et l'auxiliaire des
carences du gouvernement le conseil
d'état et l'auxiliaire des carences de
l'état quand on lit la décision on
constate qu'ils l'expliquent par le fait
que l'état n'est pas en mesure de
fournir des masques à tout le monde
alors d'un côté l'état dit je vais
fournir des masques aux magistrats et
aux greffiers qui sont dans les
audiences
et dans le même temps il reconnaît que
les avocats sont des auxiliaires de
justice qu'ils participent à ce
processus judiciaire dans les audiences
mais ont ils doivent se débrouiller
cette décision est vraiment content
traître est consternante très clairement
le conseil d'état est devenu
l'auxiliaire de la police administrative
décidée par le gouvernement
et deuxièmement la conséquence c'est que
le conseil d'état n'est plus un contre
pouvoir et que la justice ait des
berthet fondamentales sont aujourd'hui
mises en quarantaine par l'état
d'urgence sanitaire que le conseil
d'état valide à tous égards rennais
soignants eux aussi déplore le manque de
masques met à disposition et pas
seulement à bron en banlieue lyonnaise
il accule direction de profiter de
l'épidémie pour fermer les unités qui ne
rouvriront jamais un plan de
suppressions qui concerne son lit et
quatre services et explications de rania
berrada avec louis car maillot qu au
vidage un mot inventé par le personnel
du centre psychiatrique du vinatier à
bron dans la banlieue lyonnaise
les quelques 900 soignants qui exercent
ici estime que leur direction profite du
colis de 19 pour fermer des unités qui
ne rouvriront pas après l'épidémie
au total ce sont 100 lits répartis dans
quatre services qui seraient concernés
par ce plan est ce qu'on dénonce c'est
que la direction en pleine crise du
corona virus décide de fermer une unité
de 25 lits alors que l a déjà fermé plus
de 100 lits sur l'hôpital
au prétexte d'accueillir des patients
coronavirus or on accueille quatre
patients coronariens sur l'hôpital sa
porte pas son nom mais c'est ça c'est il
c'est la destruction des délits de
psychiatrie publique sous prétexte de la
crise du coronavirus il décide de fermer
les lits et de mettre en place les leur
projet qu'ils avaient en place qu'ils
avaient en tête avant de faire avant la
crise du corona virus en plus de la
suppression des lits et de la fermeture
des services
les soignants dénoncent un manque de
moyens ceux qui prennent en charge les
patients atteints de colite 19 serait
sommé d' utiliser les masques avec
parcimonie le confinement et toutes les
mesures qui sont mises en place par le
gouvernement sont là pour cacher qu'une
seule chose c'est leur incurie leur
incapacité à nous tant à faire tester la
population les gens malades et leur
incapacité à nous fournir des masques
puisque vous savez qu'ici au vinatier
les collègues qui travaillent dans les
unités qu'ovide on leur demande de faire
des économies sur les masques ffp2
d'accord
depuis le début de la crise la direction
interrompu les réunions d'information
hebdomadaire qu'elle tenait avec les
syndicats pour les tenir informés du
plan de suppression des lits face à ce
mutisme
les soignants menacent de manifester
tous les jours jusqu'à ce que la
direction renonce à son plan et au
luxembourg le port du masque est oubliée
obligatoire pour tous les habitants le
grand duché a entamé le déconfinement du
pays
hier ce sont d'abord les professionnels
du btp qui ont été autorisés à reprendre
leurs activités d'ici un mois les
universités lycées écoles et crèches
pourraient rouvrir à tour à tour à
condition évidemment que chacun respecte
le port du masque le gouvernement
insiste sur ce fait pour envisager la
reprise des autres activités économiques
et pour témoigner de la situation au
luxembourg nous sommes avec catherine
verdier qui résident sur place et qui
exercent d'ailleurs au luxembourg en
tant que psychologue bonsoir catherine
verdier merci d'être avec nous en direct
alors le port du masque évidemment c'est
quelque chose qui nous intrigue en
france puisque vous le savez on a une
petite polémique sur le sujet pas
franchement utile au départ pour les
membres du gouvernement qui devient de
plus en plus utile même obligatoire
bientôt dans les transports comment ça
se passe chez vous au luxembourg ça veut
dire que chacun chaque habitant reçoit
un masque oui tout à fait tout à fait
depuis le début on a eu au départ du
confinement il ya eu quelques
difficultés à obtenir des masques mais
au fur et à mesure ça c'est ça c'est
bien ça s'est bien améliorée et puis
effectivement hier pour le
la première journée du déconfinement
chaque foyer a reçu un paquet avec cinq
masques par personne donc cinq masques
chaque chaque personne du foyer a reçu
cinq masques pour démarrer et les
entreprises et les sociétés qui ont
démarré effectivement aussi lundi les
entreprises du btp ont effectivement
reçu des masques pour les employés
puisque c'est la condition obligatoire
pour un déconfinement alors justement
vous parlez de déconfinement condition
obligatoire porter un masque
on imagine qu'il y à d'autres mesures à
respecter dans une distanciation sociale
quelles sont les autres mesures à
appliquer pour les luxembourgeois ni
tout à fait tout les toutes les mesures
barrières qui existent et qu'ils doivent
continuer d'exister obligatoirement
toute la distanciation social au niveau
des au niveau des magasins des magasins
dénuement d'alimentation une distance à
respecter qui est de m et puis et puis
les sorties qui sont pas qu'ils sont pas
libres non plus on est moins confiné et
on a les autres on n'a pas besoin
d'autorisation pour sortir mais disons
qu'on reste dans le même cadre dans le
même cadre qu'auparavant quoi alors il
ya moins d'habitants en france un
évidement toutes proportions gardées m
et enfin le bilan est tout de même très
léger plus de 70 décès à quoi attribuer
ce bilan assez léger comment était géré
cette épidémie au luxembourg
je crois que je crois qu'elle a été très
très bien gérée qui lie à les hôpitaux
avait tout ce qu'il fallait pour pour
gérer cette crise il ya eu 34 milles je
crois test
d'opérer sur six cent mille habitants
donc c'est beaucoup voilà les y avait
6000 réservistes également aussi pour le
pour aider aux hôpitaux je me suis
présenté mais je crois qu'il n'avait pas
besoin de moi voilà mes donc il y avait
il y avait du matériel il ya eu un
hôpital supplémentaires qui a été
construit juste prend fin moi je les ai
vues de mes fenêtres voilà et puis tout
le monde était mobilisé et tout le monde
était sur le pont et je crois
franchement que les les toutes les
mesures barrières ont été soigneusement
respectée alors vous parlez d'un hôpital
qui a été construit évidemment ça nous
intrigue en si peu de temps
oui oui tout à fait tout à fait une
annexe à l'hôpital principal qui a été
construite en quelques jours les a vus
on les a vus construire ça en quelques
jours en très peu de temps à la chinoise
en fait
autre information nous en france
importante 1 jean michel blanquer qui a
donné son calendrier détaillé pour les
écoliers ça va se passer en trois fois
chez nous expliquez nous un petit peu
comment ça s'est passé au luxembourg
parce que ici évidemment ça crée le
débat beaucoup de professeurs non non
pas franchement envie de retourner
travailler ils dénoncent des conditions
sanitaires qui ne sont pas respectées
comment ça s'est passé chez vous ça va
se passer c'est à dire que le
gouvernement autorise certaines
professions à recommencer à travailler
donc le btp hier les fleuristes les
magasins de bricolage
il ya un laps de temps qui va s'écouler
sans que quoi que ce soit se passe et
puis le 4 mai démarre effectivement pour
les écoles les derniers en fait on a
luxembourg où on fait l'inversé de la
france c'est à dire qu'on met les on met
à l'école en dernier les petits les plus
jeunes donc en premier ce sont ceux qui
passent le bac etc
en deuxième le 11 mai les collégiens et
des lycéens
et puis le 23 mai sont prévues les
petits primaires et maternelles et
crèches
alors ya eu évidemment un confinement
chez vous aussi vous êtes un psychologue
on le rappelle quelles sont les
conséquences vous est peut-être un tout
petit peu plus de recul que nous pour en
parler
les conséquences psychologiques du
confinement les conséquences elles sont
nombreuses on est on est on est tous en
situation de stress post traumatique
même si les conditions sont privilégiés
même s'il ya pas beaucoup de cas au
regard du regarde la population ça reste
un confinement avec toutes les
inquiétudes qui vont derrière avec les
incertitudes pour le pour l'avenir
également donc
voilà maintenant depuis là depuis hier
en fait
hier c'était la fin des vacances
scolaires des vacances de pâques au
luxembourg est depuis hier c'est très
curieux mais c'est très difficile pour
les enfants de reprendre ce rythme ainsi
que pour les parents les mamans et j'ai
plusieurs demandes de consultation alors
j'en avais pas beaucoup avant mais j'ai
plusieurs demandes de consultation pour
pour les aider parce que le la reprise
la reprise des cours à l'école à la
maison par dont la reprise du travail du
télétravail etc
c'est c'est beaucoup c'est vraiment
beaucoup je crois que les gens n'ont
vraiment vraiment marre si je puis me
permettre
merci beaucoup catherine verdier
psychologue et thérapeute fondatrice
notamment de psy famille et merci pour
votre témoignage de cette situation au
luxembourg et c'est la fin de cette
émission on peut écouter vous le savez
en raison de la crise du corona virus on
se retrouve pour un point complet sur
l'actualité ce sera demain à 8 heures du
matin heure française en attendant tous
les programmes continuent comme
d'habitude sur rt france excellente fin
de soirée à tous
[Musique]
certains disent que nous ne sommes pas
une chaîne française
d'autres affirment même que nous ne
sommes pas journalistes mais vous
[Musique]
savez-vous vraiment qui nous sommes
les valeurs que nous défendons la
liberté
la liberté d'expression et d'opinion
nous défendons l'égalité l'égalité des
chances pour tous
[Musique]
nous sommes une équipe
nous sommes cette diversité qui fait la
france
et nous en sommes fiers
[Musique]
et si vous veniez voir par vous même on
vit tous les jours sans faire attention
que tout en dépend c'est l'unité de
mesure de toute chose une convention
admise par tous s'il arrive quelque
chose tout s'arrête
[Applaudissements]
vous conviendrez que c'est l'argent qui
fait tourner le monde
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
ap
peu importe que ce soit des bitcoins ou
du bon vieux cash
nous vous parlerons de tout sans langue
de bois est ce qu'on sait combien
d'enfants sont victimes de ces violences
et qui sont concernés par ces drames qui
se déroule dans le huis clos familial